[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so before corona happened i was actually
kind of a morning person i would get up
around 6 6 30 am however since the
pandemic my sleeping schedule has been
all over the place going to bed around 2
3 4 a.m is not so strange anymore
snapping my afternoons away so yeah
anyways i really want to fix this before
uni starts that's why i decided to wake
up at 6 a.m for a week do a good reset
and live my best life let go
[Music]
if you don't know the way we can stop
and make a change
[Music]
everything's fine
i wouldn't expect any more from this the
situation's in line
with every story that i heard
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so i actually worked at the sleep and
memory lab for a little bit
therefore i want to delve in a bit more
into sleep and its important benefits
there are multiple functions and
benefits to a good night of sleep for
example it enhances our ability to learn
it improves our physical and
cardiovascular health it regulates our
appetite improves our concentration
builds immune response and allows for
creativity so if you are sleep deprived
all of these are impaired that's why i
think it's important to find a sleeping
schedule that works for you and maybe
that's waking up early like me but maybe
you are an evening person and that's
also okay just tune in with your body
and see what works best and try to get
your eight hours and then you're all
good
there's a
place okay so i woke up half an hour
later then
[Music]
[Music]
there's a sun
in the sky
there's a cloud drifting by
all kinds of birds make you wish you
could fly and in the distance i see
someone waving at me
i hope that it's you but who else could
it be
so
again i woke up
too late
i think it's basically because i got too
bad tonight like last week i slept at
12
um
which
technically is
too late
if you want to wake up
at six so
i kind of just
to fix my keeping schedule but yeah
yesterday another day
i'm gonna try again maybe i'll extend
this challenge by like one or two days
to really
fix this
so i think it's day four
of waking up early and it's now almost
10 so it's already pretty bright outside
but i kind of wanted to film myself to
give a little bit an overview
of how the challenge has been going so
far so i have to say the first two days
were really good i got so much done i
woke up exactly around 6 6 15
which is when i set my alarm and i
immediately i exercised i ate breakfast
which usually i just started eating
breakfast around 12 which is lunch i
guess yeah so that went really well but
then day three and four which is the day
happen and i think now
the exhaustion just starts setting in
because i've been not really going
uh to bed on time yeah so i think fixing
my night routine is actually more
important
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay yeah so it's at the moment 10
10 28 and i'm gonna try to sleep early i
think i'm gonna
watch
a little bit because i just came home
from
work um so i'm actually
tired but not
relaxed enough yet to fall asleep
immediately
um tomorrow is day six i think of waking
up at 6am and it's gonna it's going a
bit better i fall asleep a little bit
earlier now around 11 quite naturally um
whereas before i fell asleep around one
so that's going pretty good
yeah i think this is just the most
important that
you fall asleep on time and then you can
wake up on time
i'm gonna try to wake up
early tomorrow do a little bit of work
hopefully also do a little bit of
exercise that's kind of nice
a little bit of journaling
maybe some meditation even although i
still find this
really hard so we'll see how that goes
yeah and i do really notice that i'm
super productive in the morning so
having those two three extra hours
that i can just focus on my research
mainly and just kind of get this
out of the way so that the rest of the
day i can just
kind of more do things
i want to do or like go to a yoga class
or it's just kind of nice instead of
having the thought in my mind every time
that i didn't do enough for my research
for my work
until now that was the biggest benefit
of waking up early so i'm gonna watch
a little bit of a series
uh kim's convenience store that i've
been watching the last few days it's
super funny and one episode is just 20
minutes so that's really good before
going to bed and i think i'm going to
read a little bit
i'm now reading this book
clara and the sun and it's super fun
nothing is really happening but
it's very relaxing i think very sweet
very cute so i'm going to do that and
then i'll update you tomorrow see ya
okay
so it's morning
it's
5
[Music]
55.
and i'm
actually really tired
[Music]
yesterday i couldn't sleep that well
um
i was just awake for a really long time
so i'm gonna do a little bit of
journaling
right now to wake myself up a bit
but then i think i want to start working
straight away
to kind of eat the frog as they say
get that out of the way
then hopefully do a little bit of
editing and perhaps even a little bit of
exercise
it's gonna start
my favorite um
yeah day six
it's already the last day
looking forward to that
[Music]
see you
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
i like
it
[Music]
you